throughout the hello world project here
that you've got it's a very simple
application that uses endpoints what I
want to do now is just talk you quickly
through the code so that you understand
how to define endpoints so you see how
to call them from a web page so let's
take a look at the files in the hello
world endpoints application so here you
see here in source main Java in the con
Google training HelloWorld package you
see the Java files there are three Java
files constant Java
hello class Java and hello world
endpoints Java so contents dot Java
defines some constants as you might
expect
hello class doc Java is a very simple
class we'll look at in a minute and then
hello world endpoints doc Java defines
the endpoints used in the application so
thus Oster contains the main folder
which contains the Java and the web app
folders we just looked at Java but now
we're going to look at web app so the
web app folder contains the static files
the index dot HTML other HTML files if
you had them JavaScript files any static
content it also contains the web - INF
or web anis folder and this folder is
common to all web applications and it's
where you configure your application so
for App Engine apps you have to have the
app engine - web.xml file which we
already looked at which is where you
configure the things that are specific
to your App Engine app in particular you
have to specify the app ID if you want
to deploy it to appspot another file in
here is web dot XML and let's take a
quick look at that
so web dot XML is where you would
configure servlets if you have them in
your web dot XML you should see that you
have the system service servlet and it's
mapped to comm Google App II server SPI
system service servlet and this SPI
means endpoints so this servlet is
crucial to your application if you want
to use endpoints
basically you must have the com Google
APIs server SPI system servlet in your
app if you want to use endpoints also
see we define the Welcome file here
which is index dot HTML which is pretty
much the default another configuration I
want to draw your attention to
is this one here for the security
constraint where we specified that all
web pages must use HTTPS and this is how
we specify it by setting the transport
guarantee confidential so whenever you
see this in your web dot XML it just
means that when the apps running on
appspot if the user goes to it without
using HTTPS they'll be redirected to
HTTPS okay
so back in the web app dot you see
there's also hello J s and there's index
dot HTML and these are the two files
that this app uses in the web UI or in
the web front-end
hello J s contains the JavaScript
functions used by the app and index.html
is the home page for the app and it
shows the two buttons and the input
field and here you see the two buttons
and the input field